you've come under ferocious pressure for
three weeks now on you on your family
it's been very difficult for your
daughters their young girls I can only
imagine as a father myself I have a
daughter who's around the age of one of
your girls incredibly difficult
there comes a point perhaps
when the pressure is just so relent
relentless
that you do think about what you should
do
with yourself and your future
many people think you should resign as
president
what are you going to do
I love so much my Lotus um and they they
love me so so much I
am very happy I'm very proud of them
very very proud of them they are very
near
to me
about Madison Nation yes I'm going to do
thank God yeah I'm going to yes because
I cannot continue my work what was the
final moment for you was it talking to
your family your dad perhaps yeah my my
father my daughters I spoke with with
them
um it's not they know is is not a
question about me and some friends very
very close to me
and they say to me Luis now
you have to focus in your identity and
to continue your life
because
if you know probably you are going to
that much people you love on the sport
you love and the beat you build with
some people a long time ago now it's
very very near the resolution last
September in one year
then when someone is not thinking only
about
himself because I had to support a lot
on this three weeks
but this uh more a question of not only
me
and then an attitude of an attitude of
me can affect
third party is very important and this
is the in this situation now the more
intelligent and the thing I have to do